let me segment because I did write a
book and I want to talk about this on
this episode because I like both of you
and and it's going to get better views
than the other ones
that's why I'm bringing it up now I
wrote a book and well Travis will edit
the uh uh the whatever graphic into the
thing and and you have a book yes which
is [__] awesome I do and it just
actually came out in um don't show his
book show his book no no but there it is
there's there's Tim's mine just got
reprinted they just got uh the paperback
release just came out but this looks
awesome your your title death by Boomers
how the worst generation destroyed the
planet but first a child
it was an amazing title no it's great
and what it is is my father is 70 and my
mother is God only knows where she is
she may not be with us anymore but what
I wanted to do before they died was just
one more disgraceful moment yeah like a
head hung low moment where I could share
all these like horrific stories uh from
growing up with boom I love Boomers
boomers are funny it's not a woe is me
book yeah boomers are deeply cell
selfish narcissistic monsters sent to
destroy the Earth they've destroyed
Society
um they are they viewed their children
as an obstacle and an impediment to
their own success for sure they were
jealous of their children they liked
when their children failed they set
their children up in many cases to fail
um they were hateful horrible people uh
they were
um completely divorced from reality they
have Tangled themselves up in conspiracy
theories you could find them on Facebook
right now oh yeah you know it's like
they're as soon as they got technology
they used it to spread hate and Division
and fear
all they believe in is fear-mongering
and and dividing people they because
they believe that's how they benefit
they were the luckiest generation other
than the few of them who died in Vietnam
enough uh we've heard about that the
rest of them had Charmed lives with
great uh peace time and they were given
and inherited this whole country and
destroyed it and my my friend I mean my
my father you know when I told him I was
like an alcoholic I was like I was a
drunk and I didn't say I'm an alcoholic
but I said to him like I'm hanging at a
bar every night I'm drinking every night
and instead of saying like you should
get help yeah my father goes son like an
old man Barr has played a role in every
Dylan's life wow he goes your uncle
Tommy went to Buckley's I used to go to
a place called The Bitter at like cool
it was it they're so
like my father I was smoking cigarettes
13 years old smoking cigarettes a front
seat of his car he let me smoke
cigarettes and he goes you know what's
good about you you never smoke him down
to the filter
he goes You Never Smoke him down to the
end he goes That's what's good about you
that's an amazing compliment for my dad
yeah so these are the type of people
they were you got to internalize like
that is what's good yeah he's like it
never smoke and he goes That's what's
good about you and I threw him out the
window and he goes you know and that's
like a picture like
like her kids talking about what kids
like with their [__] self-esteem
comes from and then they get to you
because I'm used to I didn't I do that's
really good yeah I never saw them down
well I did what the trans kids do now I
go if you don't let me smoke I'm gonna
kill myself
that's what the trans kids do they go
you give me tits from out of here yeah I
would go you have to let me smoke so
they were getting divorced and my
father's like well he's just smoking a
pack a day
it's not a big deal I spoke for years
and I would just smoke my grandmother
let me smoke in her house and my
friend's parents my friend Ryan's my
friend Ryan was dating a stripper he's
my friend is in jail now he was dating a
stripper
you know the like Indiana's Most Wanted
she was on Indiana's Most Wanted so like
state troopers came to the house once my
friend Ryan answered the door and like
they were like uh and they were like
doing identity theft they're doing bad
stuff and the the troopers were like
where is she and he goes I don't know
what you talk about they go listen if
you don't tell us where she is she
you're an accomplice so like again where
is she and he my friend just was there
like two seconds and then just looked at
the cops and went she's in the kitchen
and they come and they take this woman
out in cuffs and the Boomer parents are
kind of unfazed yeah and literally that
night for dinner we're all sitting there
and his mother's like you know what I
want to do what about a condo in Naples
how about Naples Florida I mean it's
gorgeous the restaurants are great this
is after a woman had been taken out of
the house in handcuffs they were so
crazy so the book is just a collection
of like these stories of these crazy
people that boomer generation is about
one of the worst like looking at a
problem and be like can we get out of
this right now and then just change
topic yeah it was never about like I
feel like that's because they were
raised Yeah by real [__] neanderthals
at least emotionally yeah you think
about it like a boomer is raised by
someone born in like 1910 or right right
they had no skill set yeah nothing given
to them so then no emotional life no
they're like dogs well Boomers also have
this very interesting victimhood complex
like they're always aggrieved they're
aggrieved like every time you're on the
phone with one of them like you know
like my aunt for example during covet
she goes I hope everyone gets this
vaccine because I'd like to do some
trash traveling and I've worked my whole
life I'm like everyone's worked their
whole life yeah yeah everyone's work
they're home who hasn't worked they're a
whole lot like she does I've worked my
whole life like I'm like everyone's
worked their whole life you crazy [__]
like of course they're [__] but again
it was all about her she's like I'd like
to travel what about me what about me oh
my God I just remember what my dad liked
about me yeah because you know what's
good about you yes you're a girl but you
don't talk too much sometimes women
that's nice that is a nice comment see
that's nice yeah I like that on the
filters you're not a chatty broad yeah
yeah yeah
my father would say things to me give me
this advice like we'd be in a car he'd
be like son never overestimate your
value and then he'd go he goes what you
do someone else will do too he goes he
goes he would say things like that you
know like he would just have these like
oh there very like you know the thing is
about these these comments too is if you
were to ask your dad or your dad about
saying that they'd be like yeah what's
wrong with that right they're oblivious
to the fact what that means for me my
parents used to introduce the three of
us to people yeah and like I had two
older sister and younger sister and they
would go my older sister's Maria they'd
be like this is Maria she's an a student
she's a great athlete she's creative she
dances she's like just like just full of
life she's this amazing kid and this is
Jane she's our baby she's adorable she's
sweet she's she's just the most the
cutest little sweetest girl and then
they would be like this is Tommy
he's nice
I go is that it like that's the end of
the thing you were a man you had to
stand on your own exactly they were just
like well we we take care of the girls
yeah like you gotta yeah like you're I
was an only child and my mother used to
like call me in and go
she would call me and she said quietly
she goes I always wanted another child
and your father didn't give me another
child and I don't know if this marriage
is going to work out because I always
wanted another child I've just always
wanted more children yeah and he's
denied me that and I want another child
and I would just sit there and go okay
thank you thanks for that I'd go all
right
so I love my mother and I do love my
mother but she was a horrible person but
also a lovely person yeah she was a
great person and the thing is that that
when we talk about our parents and we
criticize yes we criticize them from a
valid place yes but people are not
one-dimensional no so you can be like
look my mom's crazy or horrible all
these things but that doesn't fully
Define her you still have this stuff we
used to swim she like she taught me how
to swim she was a swim coach and I swam
a mile in the bay when I was six and
Jesus Christ yeah she used to get all
the neighborhood kids and we'd all like
swim at like 5 a.m and she would like
train them how to be like good swimmers
and she was really good she was really
good with that she was really good like
an aquatic person yeah and she was like
very much committed to that and then I
was an actor and she was committed to
that from when I was like probably seven
I started acting and I acted till I was
about 12. and she really tried and we
went and I do like it I did
um I just never had that big break where
it was like this changes your life yeah
and me and her went on a tour for like
four months with this touring musical
Annie Get Your Gun
and she and we would be on the tour bus
every night and then we toured with the
whole production and then yeah that they
put me in an amstell light shirt what's
better than that
take a look at me and my dad right there
look at his face I was just I was
singing this song about sucking [__]
right there
I was singing song about sucking dick
and the [__] comes out of the dick
he was like this is you said this was an
Irish folk song
um the priest has a big guy
so but like you know she was with me for
that yeah and then I started doing drugs
and she went insane so we went our
separate ways but we I still love her
she went a little nutty and I and I just
at 12 years old 13 years old I started
using cocaine and smoking weed and
obviously weed first I'm not nuts yeah
yeah but weed and blow and some Vicodin
and my friend's mother was a hooker and
sold his drugs and we loved her she's in
the book we love them all did your mom
do drugs too never she did
over-the-counter drugs she would take
Sudafed I'd she would drink like
prevental cough syrup and tab she loved
tab soda and prevental prevental cough
syrup and like Sudafed and like she
loves an over-the-counter cocktail yeah
to just keep her going